bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la vie d'une étoile sur terre le
ciel nocturne est illuminé d'une
multitude des toiles depuis des
millénaires on observe ces étoiles qui
semble fixer à la voûte cosmique
cependant elles sont loin d'être fixes
comme les humains les étoiles naissent
vivent et finissent un jour par mourir
laissant place à de nouvelles étoiles
plus jeunes
l'univers est principalement composé de
gaz et de poussière c'est dans l'un de
ces nuages de gaz et de poussière que va
naître une étoile sous l'action de la
gravité les particules du nuage vont
s'attirer les unes les autres et un amas
de matière va se former au fil du temps
cet amas va aggloméré de plus en plus de
matières et ainsi accumulé de plus en
plus d'énergie de cette façon là ma de
gaz va chauffer et se mettre à rayonner
il sera bientôt une étoile mais c'est
pour l'instant une protoétoile car il
n'est pas encore stable et continue de
s'effondrer sur lui même
au fur et à mesure alors que la
protoétoile continue de ce comprimé sur
elle-même par la gravitation la
température au sein de son noyau va
s'élever de plus en plus jusqu'à
atteindre environ 10 millions de degrés
celsius
c'est alors à cette température très
élevée que l'hydrogène va se mettre à
fusionner donnant ainsi de l'hélium
cette réaction thermonucléaire très
puissante va relâcher une énergie
phénoménale vers l'extérieur
lorsque sa température est élevée
les réactions thermonucléaires vont
générer une pression très forte vers
l'extérieur de la protoétoile ce qui va
la forcer à augmenter de volume mais en
se dilatant la protoétoile devient moins
denses et ainsi elle se refroidit par
conséquent comme sa température diminue
la fusion nucléaire va baisser
d'intensité et la gravité va à nouveau
pouvoir forcer l'astre à se comprimer
sur lui-même jeu va et vient entre les
deux forces va permettre à l'étoile de
se stabiliser sa pression interne
compense la gravité ce qui l'empêchent
de se fondre et sur elle même
l'astre va alors pouvoir commencer sa
vie des toiles stable durant cette
période de stabilité qui peut durer des
centaines de millions voire des
milliards d'années l'étoile est en
équilibre et continue de produire de
manière régulière sa propre énergie
notre soleil par exemple est aujourd'hui
dans cette phase stable de sa vie il est
en équilibre depuis environ cinq
milliards d'années
il le sera encore pendant les 5
milliards d'années à venir ainsi les
étoiles naissent dans des nuages de gaz
et vivre en consommant lentement leur
carburant par des réactions
thermonucléaires cependant toutes les
étoiles ne sont pas les mêmes il en
existe par exemple de différentes masses
la masse d'une étoile d'influencé
plusieurs de ses caractéristiques
tout d'abord sa couleur en effet une
étoile peu massive est en froide
elles apparaîtront rouge orangé comme
par exemple notre soleil et al'inverse
des étoiles très massives qui sont
extrêmement chaude apparaîtront blanche
voire bleu on les appelle alors des
géante bleue
ensuite la masse d'une étoile va
également influencé sa durée de vie en
effet plus une étoile va être massive
plus elle va devoir générer de l'énergie
pour s'opposer à la gravité est ainsi
plus elle va se consommer rapidement de
cette façon alors que notre soleil vivra
au total 10 milliards d'années
une étoile de trois fois sa masse ne
pourrait vivre que 300 millions d'années
et une étoile de 30 fois sa masse ne
vivrai que 60 millions d'années une
étoile va vivre en produisant
continuellement l'énergie qui lui est
nécessaire pour rester stable et ce à
l'aide de la fusion nucléaire
mais à la fin de sa vie après avoir
épuisé la majeure partie de son
carburant
l'étoile ne peut plus générer l'énergie
nécessaire à la stabiliser tandis que
son noyau va ce comprimé sous la gravité
l'étoile va gonfler et se refroidir
jusqu'à former une géante rouge de
plusieurs dizaines de fois sa taille
initiale
prenons d'abord le cas d'une étoile
similaire au soleil
après avoir formé une géante rouge
l'atmosphère de l'étoile va lentement se
diluer dans l'espace alors que son noyau
va continuer de se comprimer jusqu'à
former une laine blanche
cette naine blanche qui au départ brille
par sa chaleur va se refroidir très
lentement jusqu'à finir par s'éteindre
si l'on considère maintenant une étoile
de dix fois la masse du soleil
le scénario va être différent en effet
soumises à de très haute énergie
l'étoile va exploser le noyau se
contracte brutalement et le reste de
l'étoile est projeté dans l'espace
ce phénomène est appelé explosion de
supernova ne durant que quelques jours
maximum
c'est un phénomène extrêmement puissant
et très lumineux vue depuis la terre
c'est un point qui s'illumine
soudainement dans le ciel nocturne après
avoir explosé
l'étoile laisse derrière elle un résidu
très dense une étoile à neutrons entouré
d'une immense structure de matières qui
a été expulsé par la supernova dans ce
gigantesque nuage de gaz et de
poussières naîtront plus tard de
nouvelles étoiles
enfin si les toilettes assez massive par
exemple de 30 fois la masse du soleil
le résidu qu'elle laissera derrière elle
après avoir explosé sera tellement dense
que son attraction gravitationnelle
empêchera même la lumière passant trop
près de s'en échapper
c'est un trou noir